heroic Navy officers sacrificed their
lives saving colleagues and a civilian
expert on board when they deep-sea
vessel caught fire on Monday our senior
correspondent Margazhi EV is in the city
of Murmansk close to where the tragedy
occurred Morris what's the mood like in
the city today well to be honest with
you it is it is gloomy it's in the air
here the entire city is traumatized
Russians especially a very sensitive to
disasters at sea and this this was a
catastrophe 14 sailors 14 high ranked
sailors professionals career officers
killed in this in this blaze abroad the
deep sea scientific research vessel that
caught fire undersea in the Barents
barren sea just off the coast of
movements you'll be hard-pressed to find
a family here in Murmansk a city of 300
thousand people without a relative who's
a sailor who's who's in the Russian Navy
so you know really hits close to home
just behind us as a commemorative
service held earlier today the names and
ranks of all the officers have been
published seven of them captain's first
rank one of the most senior officer
positions in the Russian Navy we've had
condolences pouring in from all over the
world even the Pope has expressed his
condolences to all those who who died
who suffered in this unfortunate
accident
Theresa may the prime minister of the UK
also sent her condolences it really was
a painful a very painful experience for
the entire city full of Russian churches
across the country have have welcomed
people playing flowers you know offering
offering their condolences nevertheless
we've learned a few details about what
happened exactly
this deep-sea research vessel was
conducting research studying the
hydrosphere in Russian territorial
waters off the coast of
motorman's gonna ban see when a fire
began in one of the compartments the
crew apparently acted heroically when
the fire began they evacuated an
industry representative a civilian who
was abroad they shut the hatch behind
him and continued to fight the fire
14 14 people died apparently from
asphyxiation from from the gases
submariners acted heroically in the
critical situation from a compartment
that was engulfed in fire they first
evacuated the civilian and in this
through representative men close the
hatch behind him to prevent the fire
from spreading throughout the deep water
vessel the chief of Russia's Navy has
taken the investigation into his hands
he's in charge of it in two weeks he
should offer a report as to what
happened who's responsible and what will
what will come of it Vladimir Putin is
keeping up-to-date nevertheless some
some some details about the incident are
being kept under wraps this was a
top-secret military scientific research
vessel so some some details we won't be
able to find out the due to it being a
matter of state security thank you for
those details that's more audacity of
speaking to his life from Murmansk thank
you